one of cyberpunk's devs has reacted to
the rise in popularity of the game and
next year's E3 has an official date
cyberpunk 2077 Quest director Powell
sasco has spoken about the game's recent
Resurgence almost two years after it
first launched on his personal twitch
Channel sasco spoke candidly about
cyberpunk 2077's turbulent launch in
late 2020 and how it was Unreal to
recently see record numbers of players
exploring night City sasco said in part
quote to have this moment of people
liking something we did is really
feeling a bit unreal that finally people
are appreciating it it's good to be back
it's [ __ ] good to be back honestly
cyberpunk's initial launch period was
highlighted by game breaking bugs and
massive performance issues across last
gen's Xbox One and PS4 in an
unprecedented move Microsoft and Sony
began issuing refunds with cyberpunk
2077 being removed from the PlayStation
storefront for a lengthy period of time
fast forward to 2022 and cyberpunk
2077's road to recovery has seen
developers see project release massive
patches that have helped it find New
Life on console and PC the recent
cyberpunk Edge Runners anime series on
Netflix has also helped shift new fans
to the game and on Steam the game has
climbed the charts and remains in the
top 10 most played games on Steam
currently in fact cyberpunk just beat
the all-time player P count on Steam for
another cdpr game The Witcher 3.
according to analysts at Benji sales on
Twitter cyberpunk reached 104
827 players concurrently on Steam
whereas The Witcher 3 reached its peak
at 103
329. what's funny about this to me is
that The Witcher received a huge boost
in return players after the Netflix
adaptation and now like I mentioned a
little earlier the Netflix anime
adaptation for cyberpunk is also helping
it along the way so basically it seems
like if you want people to come back to
your game after for a while don't
release DLC maybe do that too but do a
Netflix adaptation because it seems to
be working for cdpr
someone someone tell Ubisoft about this
plan they need it
in non-cyberpunk news let's talk about
E3 after a three-year Hiatus from the
live events that included one digital
event in 2021 the Electronic
Entertainment Expo will return to the
Los Angeles Convention Center for E3
2023 on June 13th through 16th and it
will feature separate areas and days for
industry and consumer events the E3
business days are scheduled for June
13th through the 15th and will be
limited to registered industry members
for networking meetings and more E3
gamer days the portion of the event
that's open to the public will run the
15th and 16th in the other half of the
Los Angeles Convention Center separate
from the industry area this will allow
players to go Hands-On with the same
upcoming games as the industry peeps as
well as connect with developers content
creators and more this area will also be
open to Industry members during their
designated days E3 2023 will be the
first in-person E3 event since 2019. it
will be the first under readpop who also
organizes events like Pax New York Comic
Con Star Wars celebration and more in a
world of Summer game Fest and Publishers
and developers just kind of doing their
own showcases are you even interested in
E3 anymore and if you are do you plan on
going during the gamer days and if
you're gonna be there at the gamer days
and and I'm there during the gamer days
can I borrow a dollar
let me know